- What I am most appreciative
about my husband...
- He does all the stuff that I'm bad at
and I don't want to do.
- I really do think it's
a 50/50 partnership.
(light guitar music)
- My husband, he is
my best buddy.
- You know, I love that he involves them
in things that he loves
like sports and working out.
- He supports all my crazy ideas.
- I was a single mother when I met him,
and he has taken my oldest son
and has been a father to him.
- I think that the longer we're married
and the longer we do the
parenting gig together,
The more we appreciate each other.
- He picks them up, he'll drop them off.
He's the coach of the soccer team.
- He hates the term that
he's watching our daughter,
he's like, "No, I'm being a father."
- He's really understanding
that it is work being a parent.
- Like, he's so good about not leaving me
to just do everything.
- I'm kind of like this
monster ball of stress
who can't deal with any of the kids,
you know, I can't have all three
yelling at me at one time.
And he's just like, "I
got this, it's fine."
- He is present when he's home.
- Most important, he's trying
to raise confident kids.
(whooshing and squeaking)